for more than a decade final fantasy has
been gradually shedding parts of its
turn-based RPG routes and embracing a
more action-oriented Direction it was
only a matter of time before that focus
on action took precedence over the
role-playing elements and it appears
that Final Fantasy XV is finally the
moment the ratio has flipped as a
longtime fan of the traditional Final
Fantasy games I wasn't quite sure what
to think of this development the
turn-based classics are still some of my
favorite gaming experiences of all time
but after an extensive Hands-On with the
game I've come around on this direction
for the series or at least this entry in
it
if Final Fantasy is an action franchise
now at least it's shaping up to be a
damn good one this isn't to say the game
lacks Fantastical elements like mythical
beasts and magic spells but those are
used to complement the story in action
rather than as a layer of menu
abstraction in the fictional High
fantasy world of valastia an extremely
small number of Mortals are innately
gifted as dominance hosts for
Supernatural icons which long time Final
Fantasy fans will recognize as summoned
creatures icons are essentially weapons
of mass destruction and the various
nation-states use their icons as symbols
of their power and culture the dominance
are respected feared and sometimes even
exploited by their respective Nations as
the implied threat of the icons keeps
other nations in check the protagonist
Clive's brother Joshua was given a place
of honor as the dominant of Phoenix the
aspect of fire Cloud's journey is one of
Revenge as an attack from an invading
Army and a mysterious previously unseen
icon left his younger brother dead my
play session took place when Clive was
in his 20s obsessed with vengeance and
throwing his lot in with revolutionaries
who are looking to overthrow the social
order this segment of the story tightly
focused on just three major characters
which helped illustrate how the
political and magical machinations play
out amid the interpersonal relationships
Clive was accompanied by sudolphus
taloman this game Sid another Final
Fantasy Mainstay who is both a freedom
fighter for Magical refugees and the
dominant of Rama the aspect of lightning
their mission brought them to a castle
guarded by benedicta Harmon the doorman
of Garuda aspect of win and apparently
Sid's Old Flame Clive was also
accompanied by his loyal and very good
boy dog torgel who acts as a consistent
companion character in battle
if it seems like I'm focusing heavily on
the story it's because I find that
aspect interesting right from the start
the best final fantasy stories use
Fantastical elements to say something
about the human condition and nation
states having entered an uneasy Cold War
as each of them Harbor their own
personal living breathing wmds is a
fascinating hook that feels relatable to
real life conflicts the fact that some
Nations worship their dominance and
others imprisoned them as Living Weapons
speaks to the breadth of how we treat
things we don't understand on top of
that these super-powered beings have
their own human lives and relationships
which adds yet another wrinkle to every
interaction it's the interplay of all
these disparate elements that stands out
the most and made me care about the
characters as I explored an engaging
story wouldn't amount to much without a
strong battle system them to back it up
and on that front I was more skeptical
in Final Fantasy 16 you control one
character Clive Rosefield and the entire
story revolves around his perspective as
he matures over the course of decades
the singular focus on Clive as the sole
protagonist sometimes but not always
flanked by ai-controlled companion
characters seem to indicate a d emphasis
on juggling commands from party members
with disparate skill sets which is part
of the joy of a traditional Final
Fantasy game final fantasy 16 replaces
this level of strategic intensity with a
battle system that feels naturally
action-based but with the underpinnings
of choice as Clive proceeds through the
story he picks up abilities from the
different icons he Encounters this
doesn't make him their dominant but it
does mean that his fighting style will
be imbued with magical flourishes that
embody their unique traits for the demo
he had blessings of Phoenix fire Garuda
wind and Titan Earth you can swap
between these on the Fly and use their
unique spell abilities to complement
your array of melee attacks Phoenix for
example is particularly agile and able
to close gaps while Garuda is better for
air juggles and reaching out with its
harpy-like claws to grab enemies from
afar
Titan feels very different from both of
these with heavy attacks that often
require a brief charge to deliver their
full impact the combat system not only
allows but demands that you sweep
between these abilities since each of
them has its own cooldown that will be
in various states of recharging while
you swap to another but the cooldowns
were generous you're clearly intended to
use the full Suite of moves quickly and
to swap between them constantly at first
I found swapping between these
disorienting especially when I would tap
a Titan ability having forgotten it
requires a Charged buttonhole instead
but after only a couple of hours it felt
much more natural and I could see room
for a great deal of flexibility in the
system
each of the icon abilities along with
Clive's standard melee attacks has its
own upgrade tree I explored the tree and
upgraded a few moves unlocking new
combat abilities and enhancing the
strength of some of my favorite moves
choosing which icons to equip and how to
upgrade them looks as if it will provide
ample strategic decision making in the
moments between battles if anything I
was spoiled for Choice as the upgrade
options looked like equally exciting and
fun ways to mix up my Arsenal moves
these choices then pay off with White
Knuckle to combat when you're in the
thick of a fight Square Enix boasts that
it brought on Devil May Cry veteran
ryota Suzuki as its battle designer and
the moment-to-moment melee combat mixed
with magical ranged abilities certainly
felt reminiscent of Dante and Nero the
game that most came to mind when I
played though was another action
franchise God of War that's because the
melee battles are punctuated by icon
battles uniquely built action set pieces
that feel markedly different than the
standard battles and are particularly
exciting while traversing the castle I
came face to face with benedicta and
enjoyably scenery chewing antagonist
with dramatic Flair benedicta first
called on the aspect of Garuda to a
limited degree turning into a super
power demi-human version of herself with
wings Sid met her in kind half
transforming into Rama resulting in a
class of super powered beings that still
look roughly like they're human
characters and still acting with their
own human motivations the ensuing battle
involved fighting two other harpy-like
creatures that she summoned and later
referred to as her sisters and then
progressed to fighting her in half icon
form on a tower rooftop it was a test of
skill for all I had learned up to that
point while also tossing in cinematic
story elements
bad luck one moment when Toro leaped to
my defense clenched his jaw around
benedicta's neck was a real fist pumping
moment for me which isn't a feeling I
often associate with this franchise her
injuring and then tossing my canine pal
aside while spitting a curse made me
that much more determined to destroy her
of course this all led to the real set
piece moment an icon on icon battle
between Ifrit and Garuda like all icon
battles this was crafted to be its own
distinct encounter pitting ifra's
ability and brute strength against
garuda's ability to control the
battlefield with the wind and it was an
absolute blast a Kaiju Battle come to
life with all the dramatic underpinnings
of the human story that had informed it
the uniqueness of the encounter meant
that I was largely learning its
mechanics on the fly but this didn't
feel like it was meant to be challenging
like the traditional melee combat
instead it was made to be a spectacle
and some something to reward all of the
effort leading up to that point
to the extent that this new more
action-heavy Focus might put on long
time fans of the series Square Enix has
come up with a pretty ingenious variable
difficulty system Final Fantasy 16 has a
story mode but unlike many games that
use that name for an easier difficulty
level it instead simply turns on a
couple of helpful assists these assists
are available whether you choose story
mode or not so turning them on simply
makes them the default but it's exactly
how these assists are implemented that
makes the system so smart instead of
menu options the assists are presented
as a series of five special rings that
Grant different types of assistance one
of them simplifies combat so that's
simply pressing one button automatically
controls your combos for example while
another extends the window for a
successful Dodge you can equip these
rings in your three accessory slots but
that means you'll always have more rings
than you have space to to put them in
you'll have to choose which if any to
use to make combat easier on you this
also presents an opportunity cost as
each slot taken up by one of the assist
strings is one fewer accessory you can
use to customize Clive's other abilities
the whole system seems thoughtful and
elegant letting you still feel the
thrill of combat while gently nudging
you towards removing the training wheels
as you get more comfortable this new
focus on action combat does come at a
price though Square Enix has already
stated that Final Fantasy 16 doesn't use
an open world structure which may remove
some of the expansive scope and awe of
the traditional Final Fantasy game my
play session consisted of a fairly
straightforward level design with only
brief side paths to discover some
treasures and then proceed along the
main path The Producers noted that the
full game has wider spaces which should
provide a sense of exploration but I
didn't experience them for myself a
narrower level structure may just be the
nature of this genre shift as Final
Fantasy 16 crosses the threshold into
full-fledged action spectacle some
aspects are bound to feel different than
RPG fans have grown accustomed to for
this RPG fan though the change of pace
is welcome who knows what the future
holds for Final Fantasy but I'm
convinced that this is the right
direction for this entry in the
franchise I went in as a doubter and
came out as a True Believer eager to
experience the ride